[Musique]
dacovia exclusif plus au cinéma égale
ceci est un message du collectif
êtes-vous vraiment fatigué ou ressentez-vous
une sensibilité accrue souvenez-vous du
contact physique ou des manifestations de sentiments ou de danger
pour nous tous faisons notre part pour aider à
contenir cette maladie  est-ce que quelqu'un a vu
que
quelqu'un l'a reconnu c'est son premier
sauteur depuis un moment je t'ai regardé la
façon dont tu regardes le monde la façon dont tu vis
les choses la remue c'est bien d'
arrêter si ça continue je serai obligé de
te signaler je ne peux pas  reste loin de moi je
ne peux pas ne pas être près de toi tu réalises ce
qui se passerait si tu savais ne risque pas
ton travail ne risque pas ta vie à
qui on a dit de garder un œil sur toi
y a-t-il quelque chose que tu veux me dire tu
sais quoi  allons-nous
sérieusement envisager cela si nous restons
ici, nous serons découverts si vous prenez cette
décision, il n'y a pas de retour en arrière
peu profond où bien sûr vanille patio
évocateur exquis plus dans les cinémas
choc Teresa mystère mode développeur